welcome to this video playing lunatic ex
here with black yeah dentists
Grandmaster Michalak yep it's now got a
liberating than he had before it was
always in his 2500 and I had those
strange games where I never gets to move
that he played kind of a kind of strange
sometimes how it is okay so let's see
what we get here line of the bogo Indian
that's an interesting line not align
that I'm having in my upcoming book but
interesting yeah 95 at some point is the
only chance for why to fight for
something probably he won't play that
because he never plays a move that I
expect oh we just play it okay so let's
see what we get here I think here but
it's really not something that I know I
just know that this line is in existence
but I don't know them the details okay
mm-hmm I wonder do I give this up this
pawn or do I play rugby 8 let's let's
protect it and then try Bishop g7
we should be 70 create black is upon up
but he's under some pressure I cannot
develop that easily so push up here
taking a four
I don't really believe in whites
position I mean f5 I can maybe let's do
this so that f5 I will win a five yeah
so he protects against that I can take a
4 here we go f5 I take it
hmm
wonder they're their rules not clear FCF
6 sustained jurist definitely is f5 I
mean and then f6 is dangerous
okay anyway i will take the pawn and go
from here if I go like b6 you will
probably just play the king i wonder if
i should take actually or not have six
Queen f8
hey let's start with the movie play king
g 1 rupee 8 f 6 Queen f8 I don't know
definitely looks dangerous what is this
typical thing if I don't get checkmated
I just win this on the queenside but you
might get shake made it this is the
problem
trying to trade stuff with Ruby one yeah
I need he doesn't have any minor pieces
left so it's an it's an heavy piece of
tech only look at four I was more
expecting look at four actually not
something like that Bishop h5 is that
coming I don't know maybe put this back
here looking at you for
and that's sure what this is doing
actually age 6 I know let's go age 62 f
form if I move here come on let's move
some stuff
hard to figure out if he's really
threatening something or this is just
smoke and mirrors I don't see anything
anything resembling a threat Bishop h5
okay you look these seven I guess G for
q1 will trade stuff okay
so if he takes there and we take
everything at the end with Luke on f7 at
the end you see winning or not I don't
know can take be too
well he might the rooks are very active
okay had to do this is only chance
anyway so let's see him ponch eggs the
end I'm going C to I don't know if
that's enough but okay I just have one
minute left check check so he's got this
chicks so see tool time warning it's the
CF like I h5 h5 is a problem maybe for
the Muhammad's but then we're playing
then hope da door something hmm
I think I have to go look at the end on
h5 can shake in their first nh-5 and
rookie seven though okay I always have
Bishop b4 or a four to protect the pawn
that's very important yeah I have to do
this
Jim what is this okay if I go here it's
a draw I think don't know if I can do
more let's do this it's a draw i think
we can perpetual me here with chicks
white resides I didn't try anything here
and now no I'm getting getting stuff
promoted yeah I know I always a bit
tense against because I have a terrible
score even though I'm winning in every
and winning in every game against him
but I'm losing losing most of them due
to some tricks or whatever it was
strange you just had to draw there okay
okay yes as I expected the engine gives
a black a complete Winnie hi it is not a
serious attack but in a practical game
it's a different matter and i probably
made some mistakes here here i'm still
find according to the comp and here c3
okay what does it want to do I thought
c3 is kind of only move okay I just
wants to let let him take them ok just
this one of course I have a counter
threat on g3 that's very strong that's
very strong now we cannot take simply
check ah very strong so this this until
it's a drone check yeah that's what I
hoped I only saw a draw but you can
perpetual me of course just check check
check and draw and again here here and
this why did he do that okay well here
yes to just make a draw I don't I don't
get it you can just draw here this is
very sensible I mean he isn't he isn't
seriously tried to win here right GG for
is just a piece down it's very strange I
mean this is very easy it just is just
check check check and draw what what is
the problem I was trying to find
something better but there's nothing so
he has to he has to take the draw now
and after that is just lost yeah I don't
know this this opening is is interesting
he somehow lost the whole Queen side
before five yeah if I was given us
essentially losing four white by the
comma yeah I'm winning the Queen side
and it's not this is maybe not necessary
the engine wants to take that
immediately what I don't get is sf5
right Jake other rookies singing Oh
stupid yeah then this is just stronger
and this is just stronger I'm winning a
tempo here and now i can still decide
what to do and i don't necessarily have
to put the rope here i can let's say do
this try to get the Queen somewhere on
the D file Queen B 4 d2 with something
like that like this here yeah it's a bit
better I mean the way I play it is also
good but what had some kind of counter
play okay well thanks for watching